wedding bells are about to ring for Nick
Jonas and Priyanka Chopra that's right a
source tells et that the lovebirds are
expected to tie the knot this weekend in
India where Chopra was born and raised
before she moved to the US and of course
we are keeping up with the future mr.
and mrs. Jonas it's the fairy tale love
story we never knew we needed here's
what Priyanka told us about Nick making
the first move he texted me on the first
time was a text and just saying that you
know I think we should connect before
she becomes Priyanka Jonas the actress
filled on her romance invokes January
issue she revealed that Nick got down on
one knee the first night they met oh my
god
the first night I know that's a really
big deal and Nick's exact words after
kneeling down at Vanity Fair's Oscar
party were where have you been all my
life she also talked about the first
time there was a shift in their
relationship she said while they were on
a date in LA Nick said I love the Drive
you have and she said as a girl I've
never had a guy tell me that I like your
ambition it's always been the opposite
and I feel like we can relate right now
uh yeah this is like old school chivalry
and I'm living for it we just we love it
and another thing that happened is Nick
apparently is the first person that
she's breaking the rules for she's
publicly acknowledging her relationship
and she said this I've not known myself
like this this guy turned me into such a
girl if I could blush I'd be tomato red
right now okay probably raise your hand
if you just our feeling feels this
morning because that's so cute I know I
am filling all the fields now according
to our source they have a traditional
Indian wedding ceremony planned they're
getting married at the oom ed bhawan
palace quote Nick understands how
important it is to Priyanka to stay true
to her background and wants her to have
the best wedding day but what do you
guys think of Nick embracing Priyanka's
roots let us know across social so what
does a traditional Indian wedding until
you might ask well we did all the
research for you we don't tell you that
the celebrations take place over three
to four days there's like lots of
partying which I love yep most likely
it's gonna kick off with this party
called a Sanjeet that brings both
families and their closest friends
together so that they can all bond they
sing they dance they have good food and
good music I
that's what I want I want to be there
right in hello where was our invite and
then most likely the day before the
wedding ceremony she's going to get this
bridal henna let's see today look
gorgeous so beautiful right it's so
pretty and they do it the day before
said it's super fresh the designs are
really intricate and usually the artists
will incorporate the groom's name
somewhere in the design and the groom is
supposed to find his name before he can
sleep with the bride and people are
saying most likely she's gonna wear red
which in the u.s. would be like what but
in India it's actually referred to as
the color of light red symbolizes
spirituality and commitment fertility
all the things that you want when you
start a marriage right and she's most
likely going to change into a different
sorry
after the ceremony everything that I
wear I have to be comfortable and cute
so it's gonna be cute uncomfortable I
really like the way that they are
embracing her traditions and all the
symbolisms that are combined I think
this is going to be a marriage that's
gonna last a big here's what we predict
he will likely wear a su Romney jacket
so that's a long jacket over a pair of
fitted trousers we know that Nick is
going to be dressed to the nines
apparently he will ride in on a horse
which Nick Joe does on a horse that
image is just like you know putting him
on Prince level for me yeah Priyanka
will not be alone and wearing red on
their big day apparently for a tradition
sake Nick it may be wearing a red powder
across his forehead it's for good luck
and he also will probably wear a
traditional turban I love it I cannot
wait these wedding pictures are going to
be like the wedding pictures to top all
wedding pictures a pilot exactly I'm
really itching to see what their first
dance will be I'm hoping that Nick is
burning it up on the dance floor with
the traditional Indian dance me too and
I hope someone has their phone recording
it of course they will unfortunately
also want to keep this conversation
going across all social I met Courtney
underscore tether know and I'm at Halle
underscore Stephen okay until next time
we've got you covered